Okay.
It is time for Hatra hate mail.
Hatra.
It mailed delayed recently because of the
virus.
We finally do have our new that's a story
for the bonus show.
Maybe we have our new hatred at males and
we have one today.
Quick reminder.
What is Harriet Mail?
Because Mexico is still paying for the wall,
right?
I mean, that's what he said it all.
The campaign.
Hey, teary eyed man written by patriots who.
Hey, David Pakman because America and because
freedom.
OK.
This hatred male has what is now one of my
favorite hatred phrases.
See if you can identify it.
Take a listen.
David Pakman is a nasr's shoe.
David Pakman is trash.
David Pakman is still a shoe.
Home, please.
Identity politics while defending core dems.
You lie all the time.
LOL propaganda packman.
You're such a shill and propagandist.
Banned low IQ despite Judaism and youtube
channel a.s.a.p.
Get real job.
Please get a real job.
Get a real job has really become one of my
favorites right now because it shows me the
anger that so many people actually have that
this is my job.
You know, we've got a business now with over
a million viewers across all of our platforms
self-sustaining.
Right.
Like we we did it.
We built it from the ground up were supported
by members who say, I want to pay a few bucks
a month to support the work that we do.
We're supported by advertisers who say, hey,
when you recommend a product to your audience,
that works.
Thank you, David.
We employ four people, plus independent contractors,
lawyer, accountant, a Web team.
If that's not real, I don't know what is.
So Get a Real Job has very quickly become
one of my favorites.
Also, I don't want to ignore low IQ despite.
Judaism is a nice touch.
It's sort of like an amalgam of multiple different
discriminatory and vile ideas.
But my message to you is fight hatred.
Autism by using the coupon code.
Hatred at 40 when you get a membership on
my web site.
If you go to join Packman dot com, select
any membership and type in Hatra at 40 HKT
R.I.P otey for zero.
You save 40 percent and the Hatra, it's don't
like it.
They don't like it one bit.